this week on quandary gap lessons from
Boston living with terror
the bombs that went off at the Boston
Marathon were the first major attack on
American soil since 911 the search for
the attackers progressed rapidly two
brothers who were suspected of the crime
were identified and tracked down within
just a few days although Security
offices are directing more and more
resources at preventing terrorist
attacks it will never be possible to
stop the violence completely in other
parts of the world the last decades have
seen some of the most deadly terrorist
activity in history how can democracies
protect themselves how much freedom are
we willing to sacrifice for the promise
of more security your host today oddly
aslam hello and welcome to quadriga what
lessons can be drawn from the Boston
bombings if any is there such a thing
such as total security that's what I
want to talk about on today show
together with the three experts welcome
to Nicholas Kulish who has been the
Berlin correspondent for the New York
Times since 2007 Tom Geller is a German
journalist and a security affairs
experts who in the past has written for
The Washington Times and Egypt today and
Michailidis is a German writer and
journalist who has covered the Middle
East for many years thank you all for
being here Nicholas Kulish since 911 and
the inception of the Department of
Homeland Security the United States
government have spent a lot of money on
trying to secure that such an attack on
US soil could not happen again yet here
we are again what do you make of this
well I think the lesson is that you just
can't stop everything and you know as
much as you can focus in on al-qaida if
there's two two brothers with pressure
cookers you know you're never going to
be able to get everything there I'm
terrorism existed before nine eleven
obviously Timothy McVeigh in Oklahoma
City killed many more people than the
tone I of brothers and and you just have
to ask yourself a total total security
as either is either a myth or something
that would require the loss of all of
our freedoms together total security is
a myth says Nicholas Kulish what you
agree of course
general yes however of course we need to
try to come close to that and I found it
very impressive when President Bush
after 911 immediately said I do
everything I can to prevent any other
attack and he actually did that's not
that I'm blaming President Obama now
that he failed to well secure the
American people however obviously
President Bush had a had an agenda had a
plan and it worked so I would recommend
to look into his government and to find
out why it worked there and why didn't
now share do discuss the Boston bombing
show that all the emphasis and focus on
al Qaeda and other terrorist groups are
basically fruit I'll if two brothers as
Nicholas foolish foolish put it if two
brothers decide that they in their own
name want to commit such an act
absolutely yeah there is no total
security available it's simply not
possible to really make sure that no
terrorist attacks on this type happen I
card are is more or less a threat of the
past cada has been weakened this
organization is still in operation so to
speak but I think the danger for the
future had not only for the United
States but for other countries as well
is really radicalized individuals who
for whatever reason believe that they
need to make a message very clear and
they kill innocent people this is what
happened in Boston and I think
soul-searching the United States will be
a little bit difficult it doesn't fit
into the normal scheme this attack in
Boston yes they are Islamists to a
certain extent they are Muslim culprits
but they are not really part of any
Islamist network at least according to
our knowledge at this stage so we're
talking about radicalized individuals
and this is a big threat not only from
the Islamist side but also from the
right wing extremist side so to speak
let's think about unless breivik in
Norway who two years ago killed so many
Norwegians and nobody no security
apparatus would have been able to
prevent this once you have an individual
who is smart enough not to you know get
involved into too much internet gossip
it's it's almost impossible to track
these people down and we
to get used to these threats we have to
get used to them says me he eluded us
but it was coolish a lot of people in
the immediate aftermath of the Boston
bombings were proclaiming that terrorism
is back in the United States do you
think that was a bit over drawn the
reaction well I mean I think we'd also
had we had also had shootings at fort
hood i think it was where a military
personnel flipped out and killed many of
many of his colleagues there and again i
mean you know you look in some ways this
is almost like a hybrid I mean you have
the two disaffected young people that
could just as easily be Columbine
Colorado or could could just as easily
you know be the attacks that we saw in
Connecticut recently but then influenced
by influenced by al-qaeda
english-language propaganda on on the
internet and learning bomb-making
instructions and so I guess in that
sense I just mean that there's that
there are lots of different kinds of
violent activities taking place all the
time and and can unit can you
necessarily limit that and think of it
as being part of this international
terrorism picture tomorrow opinion this
is a bit easily being said that this
attack could not have been prevented
with the knowledge we have today we know
that the elder brother of the two
attackers was under the surveillance of
the FBI so we know it is an intelligence
failure that this could have happened
and to say that this particular attack
could not have been prevented is I think
to to easily said this is what the Obama
administration of course likes to send
out as a message in general I agree that
in general we cannot prevent terrorist
attacks this is simply impossible but
Islamist attacks on the United States I
think yes we can we can prevent and
indeed Tom killer is picking up on an
important point a lot of people are
talking about the failings of the FBI
here because it seems that Russia had
indeed won't the US about these
individuals up front what do you make of
these security intelligence failures can
you do this well you know any security
paratus is always made up of individual
of human beings and these people they
know they make mistakes I mean the same
was it was the case prior to 911
possibly it would have been you know
feasible to avoid this attack had the
you know security a parrot has been be
more efficient at that time but this is
really discussing you know about spoiled
milk I mean yes in theory it might have
been possible but in practice there are
so many people out there weirdos who are
willing to kill other people I think we
we need to be realistic yes there needs
to be you know more work needs to be
done and especially we have to be
careful not to be ideologically blind on
the right I I mean Islamist terror is
one thing is one big issue and another
big issue of course is what are the
right-wing extremists doing this is also
a problem for the United States and
there's one thing to be said what could
have been done right before the attack
there's another thing talking about the
reactions in the immediate aftermath of
the bombings look at what several
Republican congressman said they said
let's treat Jose archana if one of the
perpetrators as an enemy combatant which
would have given him the same status as
those in prison in Guantanamo what goes
through your mind when you hear these
things Nicholas Kulish that the same the
same easy answers and the same things
that have put us in some ways in this
position are not going to are not going
to help I mean we have we have a justice
system that I think is one of the best
in the world and in a case where people
commit a crime on an American soil we
can drive them on American soil we don't
have to go dumping them into semi-legal
prisons in Cuba and so on and I think
but I think this gets to like this gets
to a larger a larger debate you know
with one side saying you know we do
whatever it takes to stop any hint of an
incident and another side that says when
you have Guantanamo when you have
indiscriminate drone strikes in other
countries you basically create we create
the impression among people that you're
an unlawful power and I think that for I
think that for a lot of young angry
people America is becoming that in their
eyes and Tyler indeed let's talk about
the proposals to try this young man as
an enemy combatant at least you suggest
george w bush in the aftermath of 911
said you are not going to destroy our
way of life our values but would you say
that these proposals are already
undermining the u.s. way of life the
u.s. sense of fairness and judicial
system well yes yes in a certain way
because the freedom that America stands
for where this this spirit of freedom
and liberty has vanished a bit in the we
all were so happy that moved the whole
society the all us society recovered in
the past 10 to 12 years after 911 and
now again we have this other homeland
attack so to speak and I I agree to a
certain extent with Republicans who say
we should treat them as enemy combatants
not necessarily as you said to dump them
at Gitmo but to treat them as enemy
combatants because that's what they are
they are not just lunatics they are not
just some people who want to throw a
bomb they have a mission they have a
goal with a political goal and it is to
destroy the Western society the Western
freedom I also see naturalized citizens
of the United States well yes but we all
know where they come from and sometimes
some just use this to you know they are
Americans by passport but not by spirit
so you would be in favor of trying
tsarnaev as an enemy combatant word and
if if we look at because we've been
talking about Guantanamo indeed and if
we look at the current events that are
taking place right now in Guantanamo 84
prisoners are currently on hunger strike
because they're protesting against their
indefinite detention and most of them
are saying that they don't even know why
they're being held point point being do
you think that these kind of news and
the fact to propose these this young man
as an enemy combatant only breeds more
terror rather than less well difficult
but basically speaking I would say a
criminal is a criminal and nothing more
than that so I don't need I personally I
don't think it's helpful to talk about
enemy combatants because what does this
mean enemy combatant means you send
someone to a foreign territory to Cuba
in that case to Gitmo and they're this
person this enemy combatant will remain
under sometimes very dubious reasons
there are dozens of people who are who
are at Gitmo for one single reason no
country is willing to accept them when
they come home so this is in my view
really an expression of a moral and
legal bankruptcy of the American legal
system President Obama is very much
aware of this but he is not able to real
to constitute to persuade the more
conservative part of the American
political system to accept the idea to
either put these people on trial or to
let them go so in order to create enemy
new enemy combatants is not really you
know solving the issue and what do you
do if you really think this thought to
the very end what do you do with
right-wing american terrorists who you
know go out for shooting accidents in
some schools in the united states what
do you do with them do you also declare
them to the enemy combatants and sound
i'm trajet no i think this is not really
a solution i think they need a fair and
legal trial with all consequences of
course if this would be the case as I
said bankruptcy of the American legal
system and so forth President Obama
would have dissolved [ __ ] mo that is
what he promised before before he became
president but he learned his lesson he
understood why did mo is necessary and
this is why we still have it so I I
think it is it is in this very important
to treat them as enemy combatants
because it also sends a signal to those
who attack the united states that they
are understood as enemies we are on war
with you and if you declare war on us
then we you have to face all the
consequences and not those typical
European consequences that in the end
you as
e you ask the the perpetrator in the end
you are declared a victim as we had by
the European Commissioner a couple of
times well I think that's a very
distinct explanation of things first of
all I think it's not because mr. Obama
learned his lesson that jet ma still
exists it was simply that he could not
overcome the pressure is mainly of the
right wing in the united states of the
republicans in order to close Gitmo it's
a very delicate political issue in the
United States for four unfortunate
matters and I think we should really
stick and adhere to the to the legal
system if you think the Bush
administration's dealing with these
enemy combatants to the end we are
talking about Afghanistan we are talking
about Iraq the results not being very
satisfactory for American policy making
not to mention the suffering of the
people in Afghanistan and Iraq so I'm a
strong adherent of illegal thinking and
as I mentioned before what do you do
with right-wing combatants which the
United States have also seen what you do
with the Timothy vay do you remember who
you do you send them to Gitmo because
you declare them enemy combatants I
think this doesn't really solve the
issue and unfortunately unfortunately we
have to learn to live with this type of
terror I'm very much afraid that in the
future we will see even more attacks of
radicalized individuals and it's more
difficult to track them down I mean
psychologically speaking I think for any
country being attacked like the United
States have experienced it now in Boston
it's easier so to speak psychologically
speaking to have an enemy who comes from
abroad to say well they are Chechens
they are Pakistanis they are
Palestinians whatever it's more
difficult to admit well we also have a
homegrown terrorism this time it was
really Islamist terrorists no doubt
about that but next time maybe we have
some right where you who who thinks you
should blow up the United Nations
supposed to break this right-wing thing
up we are talking about this Islamist
attack it is one it was one and it has
to be treated differently from from
right wing attacks of generality oh
thank you differently also there's only
one category of American it's American
there's no special category for Muslims
it's if you're an American citizen
you're an American citizen it's genuine
but I just think you know I mean at this
point what you do is you you chip away
at your values slowly but
surely until you ask yourself you know
what do we have and what do we stand for
I mean you know first first it's it's
okay to take people and to illegally
render them to be tortured it's okay to
take to kidnap people and to put them in
places like you know Poland and Romania
and to do things to them then it's okay
to shoot very specific targets you know
with drone missiles then we're killing
American citizens with drone missiles at
a certain point if if you found yourself
in an argument as I have in places like
Egypt with somebody about what America
is or what America's values are it
becomes a lot more difficult to defend
and that I think actually opens us up to
not just criticism but to increase
radicalization abroad and at home and
indeed it is part of a much broader
debate which Nicholas Kulish has brought
up namely how much freedom always
willing to sacrifice for the four
promises of more security how much more
would you like to civil rights to be
limited in order to to at least create
the illusion of security tunngle at all
no III don't want to sacrifice le
liberte I agree with both of you that we
have to live with the situation but we
can still do a lot to prevent certain
certain attacks and this also every
single one of us has to to look into our
societies and see where what their
thoughts are coming from and do way more
and invest way more into prevention of
that kind of attacks so that we don't
have to give up the liberties we all
cherish so much and this is what the
Reston's civilization stands for and
there are some people who are saying
that rather than fighting and combating
terrorism we should look at the symptoms
we should fight the symptoms of
terrorism rather would you agree and
what other symptoms yeah very good
question very justified question I mean
in the case of these two Chechen
brothers I'm not really very sure about
their motivation I mean if we if we look
at it from an Islamist point of view it
doesn't really make sense from a Chechen
point of view to attack the United
States it makes absolutely no sense
because the Chechens are
a minority will then rusher and they
have been prosecuted by the Russian
regime in the past there have been very
many terrorist attacks in Russia
perpetrated by Chechens but as I
mentioned there is no whatever you know
combination of anger or wrath against
the United States by Chechens so we are
talking obviously about two individuals
who for whatever reason failed in their
integration they dislike the American
idea of freedom etc etc very difficult
to speculate on that but that's only one
aspect of terrorism the United States
are also facing criticism and terror
because you know American policies in
the past I don't want to generalize but
you know American policies have created
have arc in many parts of the world in
Iraq and Afghanistan Vietnam etc etc the
Americans have learned their lessons but
still there are so many radicalized
individuals who have good reasons from
their point of view to get you know
aggressive let's just think about these
drone attacks against innocent civilians
in Pakistan Yemen and other parts of the
world of course you radicalize whole
tribes whole region's in Pakistan and
Yemen and elsewhere and these people
will try to take revenge and this is you
know that's the price you pay as a
superpower I mean any countries is
committing mistakes maybe the United
States have committed too many mistakes
in the past 10-15 years but the
Americans especially the administration
of Obama they have learned the lessons
to a certain extent there you know
refraining from you no direct
involvement in the civil war in Syria or
in Mali in West Africa as opposed to the
Europeans the Germans the French who
appear to be repeating American mistakes
of the past no Nicholas Kulish would you
agree that the attacks on US soil or the
reaction or the backlash all the u.s.
foreign policy perhaps gone wrong I mean
I think you find when you look at
radicalized individuals that they're
often looking at the same kinds of
videos and that or that there's a
there's a step-by-step process where you
begin by looking at videos of victims of
dead people that that's blamed on blamed
on the United States and eventually you
get you get your way to the to the
bomb-making video and I think that if
you look ten years ago at the beginning
of the Iraq invasion you would have
people in Baghdad you know women going
shopping in the market
while we were shooting missiles at the
cat the Iraqi capital because they
believed that we had smart bombs and
that we would we would target the
Defense Ministry we would target the oil
ministry but we wouldn't hit we wouldn't
hit the the bazaar so to speak and and
now i think the impression kind of is
that the that bombs just just dropped
from above if an informant gives a bad
bit of information to the CIA then then
you know you're you're out of luck in
Peshawar and I think that that does that
when those attitudes change about the
United States it makes it makes it
harder for us to to defend ourselves on
a moral level I think here comes up also
a different completely other aspect and
that is only if you attack the United
States you gain publicity and the
Chechen war is or has almost been
forgotten the Europeans who always blame
the US for for the chit mo inhabitants
never cared a bit about how many died in
Chechnya they never accused really Putin
and all the others what they did there
this really dirty dirty war of the
Russians didn't interest the Europeans
the Europeans always blame the Americans
because they gained reputation with that
it's easy to bash the Americans it's
hard to bash the Russians coming back to
those two jetsons they it's not a
farfetch'd farfetch'd in speculation the
tension war is well goes calmly on but
nobody realizes it and the Europeans are
not interested in so what can you do you
do any kind of attack and you get
towards the United States and you gain
an immediate publicity so this is my
speculation about why they did that of
course I don't know either the real
reason but it makes a certain sense well
one of the perpetrators the only one who
got killed Tamerlan tsarnaev seemed to
be guided and motivated by what he
perceived to be an assault on Islam very
much the same theme that Nicholas Kulish
was talking about the one that appears
in these videos that motivates these
young people to go and commit such
atrocities would you agree with the
premise that there's such an attack on
part of the Western world on Islam well
you know I mean relations between the
Western world and Islam are of course
very complicated but in the past
especially since nine eleven I think
very many young Muslims have become
radicalized for various reasons of
course some of these radicalized Muslims
do play the play the blame game states
being responsible for any evil upon
earth but nevertheless there have been
you know failed policies in the past and
of course from a Muslim point of view
even if you're a moderate Muslim you see
military action in Afghanistan you see
it in Iraq you see it in Libya you don't
see it in Syria there is a naughty Libya
the Americans were not in Libya but
there were no pulling the strings a
little bit in the back I don't want to
criticize the military engagement in
Libya it's a different topic but I was
very much in favor of topping this
regime but from as i mentioned from a
moderate Muslim point of view you get
the impression you know being a Muslim
means that you're a potential target and
I think even when you talk about the
moderate streams of Muslim societies
there is a certain wrath or a certain on
understanding of Western policies but
I'm sorry teacher but these young men
must know that with these acts these
terrorist attacks they are only
deteriorating the image of Islam
worldwide isn't that the case absolutely
but i think that when we talk about
these radicalized individuals they do
not think that far they they have their
own personal agenda as you mentioned
before they are radicalized through
videos or through certain ideology or
maybe through their parents you never
know but in this particular case when we
talk about boston it's still a little
bit weird because they are so such is a
very small number of Chechens only
living in the united states there are
many more living in European countries
including Germany so if you are
radicalized Chechen it makes more sense
to make an attack in Paris in Berlin and
Madrid London in order to persuade the
Europeans to do something for the
Chechen cause if you want to look at it
that way but doing this harm in the
United States only means that Putin now
has a pretext to even you know continue
his suppression of the Chechens because
he says well we all in one boat the
United States and us we are fighting the
same enemy
and indeed you have already mentioned
some of the cities that have also been
hit by international terrorism Boston
and the United States of course not the
only city or other country that is has
been hit by international terrorism in
the past decade let's have a quick look
in 2002 less than a year after the sep
tember 11th attacks in the u.s. there
was carnage on the island of Bali when
suicide bombers blew themselves up at a
tourist nightclub over 200 people were
killed in 2004 just three days before
national elections in Spain coordinated
explosions in the train system in the
capital Madrid killed 191 people and
wounded nearly 2,000 more later in 2004
a group of armed separatist militants
from Chechnya and ingo chetia seeds
control of a school in the Russian city
of bezel on our the time at three day
siege ended at least 300 people were
dead many of them children
in 2008 a series of bombings and
shootings rock to the Indian megacity
Mumbai over a period of three days the
members of a pakistan-based militant
organization killed over 150 people and
wounded hundreds more Iraq and
Afghanistan have suffered more than any
other countries from terrorist attacks
in the last 10 years they have claimed
tens of thousands of lives in those
countries between 2002 and two thousand
eleven attacks they're accounted for
around a third of all terrorist related
casualties worldwide while Nicholas
Kulish we have just seen a variety of
unfortunate scenes and attacks in the
past now let's look some people are
saying there's a double standard perhaps
here involved three people have died in
Boston that that's three too many but in
hindsight and in place in context these
kind of attacks are almost a weekly
occurrence in Islamabad in Kabul and in
Baghdad you've covered back that and and
most most of the times the number of
casualties is much higher than what we
are seeing in the in the Boston bombings
do you think there's a double standard
that some people are saying American
casualties count more if you will then
casualty someplace else I mean I think
there is an element of that for sure but
I think that also in this instance the
the high-profile nature of the event I
mean people sit and watch the Boston
Marathon on television even without the
expectation of violence or something
happening and the the contrast between
the sort of the celebration and the
holiday and and the the runners and then
and then the death and the destruction I
think destruction is key just as in the
in the embassy bombings in Africa it was
often overlooked that hundreds of people
were blinded that these bombs did not
kill very many people because they were
put low on the ground but but it scores
of people lost limbs or lost lost
function but I mean I think I think it
more broadly just does one Pakistani
death get as much attention as one
American death you know absolutely not
but but the event was chosen
specifically for for a maximum media
impact you could say indeed the media
coverage about Boston has gotten a lot
of play worldwide worse the attacks for
instance in Pakistan Afghanistan or
perhaps Iraq are often rather just a
small footnote in the so-called Western
media how do you explain this well of
course as you said the Boston Marathon
is world famous in as far as I know even
227 Germans were registered to run so it
is more than just an American event it
is a world event for world peace kind of
or it stands it's one of the victims was
Chinese 103 right right it stands for
what the West actually stands for so it
is definitely an attack on Western
values and that is come together live
multicultural yeah well let's overcome
religion and where you come from and the
the Boston Marathon stood or stands for
much more than just the sporting event
of course if I if I think about when a
gunman in would run amok in East LA say
would they close down brentwood and
Santa Monica as they did in Boston sure
they wouldn't even if there would be way
more victims it has a different symbolic
meaning or he had a different symbolic
meaning imposter some have called the
the reaction in the immediate aftermath
of the ball makes not just on the part
of the media but in general it's
disproportionate would you agree well I
mean from a security point of view it is
of course very difficult to judge what
officials will decide or not of course
as an official you are interested and
not you know seeing more people killed
so it's difficult to judge from from
from a German you know from Berlin as
whether or not you know the security
apparatus was functioning well and
Boston of course it was you know quite a
big thing to shut down the city but
nevertheless you know in such a
situation you
you have to act preventively you have to
try the best you can in order to you
know avoid further further deaths but it
was still and my view very interesting
to see that this hunting down of these
two terrorists really became a witch
hunt or start next time I mean it was a
huge how shall i call it undertaking so
many people participating in this case
things went out fine but what had you
know the wrong car press being looked
upon you know when you have the media
when you have the social media you know
pointing out a certain person like
saying mr. Roslyn he is supposed to be
behind these attacks then thought not
that's all but you know I don't want to
be miss Joslyn in such a case because
when you have a whole city you know
chasing you it's very difficult to
explain well this is a misunderstanding
so I'm a little bit skeptical about this
type of witch hunt let's say and it's
quite ironic in the end it was you know
a private citizen who really gave the
decisive information as to where this
one surviving corporate and indeed
Nicholas Kulish Michailidis raises an
important point the New York Post for
instance right after the bombings
depicted two young men on their cover
basically suggesting that these might be
the perpetrators if we look at the media
coverage in general and we're all
journalists here at that you know how
would you assess how would you rate the
media coverage that has accompanied the
Boston bombings well yeah you had do at
CNN getting out ahead of itself a little
bit as well I mean I think that
something is something has changed in
the in this in the metabolism of the
speed at which the the media is supposed
to work I think twitter's contributed a
great deal to that where you know every
single person wants to be you know the
first in every instance and in a story
like this where the you know having
haven't covered the the sniper case in
law in Washington DC for instance or the
aftermath of 911 you know in the old
days you had you had a couple of hours
to sort through things to take a lead to
call somebody to check it double check
it somebody could even make a mistake on
the law enforcement side and get back to
you and before anything ended up in
print whereas now you know
basically straight from straight from a
text message in your cell phone onto the
air at CNN or or straight from a from a
photo sharing website into it you know
into a witch hunt and so I think that
news organizations are going to have to
learn to be a little more responsible
and and hopefully some way will be found
to keep social media and check as well
but I think it's not only the the news
media who are to blame but also the
recipients or those who use Twitter and
Facebook they have all sorts of
responsibility since I'm familiar with
the Middle East as well I can see the
huge difference how the young Egyptians
used the social media in comparison to
now for them for the Egyptians it was
they started a revolution it was either
we get Mubarak down or or we fail right
so it had a very serious a very serious
basis to use Twitter and Facebook two
years ago on to Tahrir place in
comparison to what we experienced in
Boston some were simply posting
photoshopped pictures and they had a
kind of excitement and fun doing this
not understanding how serious this issue
is so I I really would blame those
people whether they're young or old
doesn't matter who acted completely
irresponsible by using the social media
that way and I can really see the huge
difference is for the Egyptians there
was a lot at stake and in this case in
Boston obviously not and here you lass
do you think there's become the
sentiment if you will that it's more
important to be quick rather than
accurate yes absolutely I think so and I
think you know we shouldn't
underestimate the psychological impact
of such a terrorist attack happening in
Boston I think many individuals many
people in the United States but also
brought do of course identify
immediately with the victims for good
reasons but then of course rationality
is sometimes a little bit difficult to
achieve they
is still another interesting aspect
aspect in my view as we mentioned before
three dead people in Boston three too
many no doubt about that but still from
a psychological point of view I find it
interesting that we identify so much
with these three unfortunate victims of
this terrorist attack I mean I think in
the past year some 30,000 people were
killed in the United States through the
use of guns some most in most cases by
legal guns and yet you know people seem
to accept that 30 thousand dead people
you know killed for nothing because
they're quite absurd gun laws in the
United States at least from our European
perspective but nobody seems to care but
then suddenly there's a terrorist attack
in Boston three people get killed and
it's a huge uproar as I mentioned before
from a psychological point of view it's
of course understandable because when
the enemy comes from the outside or when
the enemy is even unknown you know it's
something that challenges you that's
that that's the type of story you know
Hollywood makes many movies on and it's
interesting to see the psychology
working at the same time you simply
don't care about that people in Syria
about that people in and back dad this
is out of the horizon for us because
it's a different world we do not
identify with people in Syria back that
but we do identify for good reasons with
people and victims in Boston that's good
to a certain extent but we should not
forget the other victims they are on
earth be it in Baghdad and Damascus Oh
be it in the United States even where so
many people are killed through these you
know quant absurd gun laws in my view I
remember right after 911 or between 9-11
and the founding of the Department of
Homeland Security I was speaking with a
Harvard professor of risk analysis and
we were talking about different how to
make these decisions of how many
billions to invest in this and how many
hundreds of millions invest in that and
and he said well of course we would save
more lives if we took a hundredth of
that money and just put up signs telling
people to wash their hands because you
could you could prevent a hundred
thousand deaths he hear that way but
obviously people care or when a when a
spaceship went to Space Shuttle crashes
you know that's the same number of
people killed as in a car accident but
the world attention is you know is
completely different and so we put we
put certain
certain over-emphasis certain
irrationality that kind of that come to
the fore and and the fear of terrors is
absolutely one of them and I think it's
then for that reason important to step
back and ask are we really prioritizing
the right things and the gun debate is a
perfect example of that have Americans
after 911 after the installment of the
Department of Homeland Security would
you say by and large up until the Boston
bombings have they felt safer I would
say that they probably do I mean the
September 11th event was so singular as
to you know you you don't think in the
way that Israelis perhaps you know fear
going to a to a club or going to a
grocery store that a bomb might might go
off that it's it's you know it's simply
not the same thing I think Americans
were more prone to complain about not
being allowed to take their shampoo on
the airplane than to actually really
really understand what was going on but
I think you know more small incidents
like this i think actually so greater
fear then sing single spectacular
incidents and the terrifying thing about
this was that you know if you if you
look at it from a lesson learned
standpoint from the terrorists
perspective and from the from the
american perspective you show small
number of people unsophisticated weapons
can so maximum fear maximum media
attention and shut down a city for
several days the incentive structure the
year that you're setting up there for
people who want to commit acts like this
is an unfortunate one what drove me
actually mad is that they those two guys
achieved what Hitler and Emperor hero
Stroh did not achieve that is to to stop
the greyhound they even stopped buses
throughout ed sir for this but a i would
i would also like to to look into when
you call the the American gun laws
absurd from an American perspective the
German wrote laws are absurd you have
the same numbers of or the death toll is
as high here in Germany for speeding you
know for this absurd durational speeding
or that the Germans want to run from A
to B on their load
ways in an well absurd high speed we
cannot identify or or or identify
ourselves with every victim so from
whatever perspective you look at it I
will recommend more to come to how the
Israelis live they live with a daily
threat for decades and they did not give
up their freedom their liberty their
democracy it has not seriously been
affected by all those daily attacks and
stinger attacks and whatever happens so
actually I think the West could learn a
lesson from the Israelis to relax in a
certain way as as as happy as it sounds
but we have to learn that lesson yeah i
think as i mentioned before I think we
have to learn to live with the threats
posed by modernity and and parts of this
threat is a threat system so to speak is
is is is really the danger of terrorist
attacks it can happen at any time at any
place there is no guarantee and and and
and whoever from the political field so
to speak preaches you know total
security will only achieve total
surveillance but not total security as
long as they're individuals who are
willing to blow themselves up and and
and and and get other people's people
killed as well you know this will happen
this will happen there's no way even if
you put a policeman at any corner at
every corner in in Boston and Washington
Berlin wherever once you have a person
who is going to blow himself up there
there there is no total protection and
we need to to live with this thread that
this is part of our you know daily risks
it's like using a car or you know
boarding a plane there always is a
certain risk that you might be dead in
the end yeah of course it's only a
theoretical fear but we should be aware
of this in terrorist attacks they are
part of our well threat system in the
Western world we have to get used to it
and let us not forget that people in the
Middle East for instance they live under
very difficult much more difficult
circumstances I mean let's not forget
the Syrians for instance they try to
survive on a daily basis on a much more
difficult circumstances so this should
teach us to a certain less a fair you
know
let's not underestimate the threat the
threat is there it's real it's a real
one but we should also you know lean
back to a certain extent well we have to
him back to a certain extent we will
lean back now because we've come to the
end of the show and indeed we perhaps
have to live with a certain degree of
insecurity no matter where we live I
want to thank my guests for sharing
their insights and they're very much
valued opinions I want to thank you out
there for tuning in and looking forward
to seeing you again next week for a new
edition of cod Riga
you